120,000 is the number of refugees the
european commission would like to
relocate within its borders over the
next few weeks european politicians have
made up their minds on how to handle the
so-called migrant crisis but European
citizens have questions and fear about
the arrival of a great number of people
from other countries and different
cultural backgrounds and my book chair
of the Foreign Affair committee answers
the three most asked questions on
Facebook what is Europe's plan to avoid
jihadists entering Europe on an alarming
scale it means that your for example
have to use very much senses and all
that information was also Europol and so
on so that we have each other giving the
the informations about jealous so that
we know when people go towards one
country but we have because of this
amount of refugees very cautious in this
question therefore the registration of
refugees is so important to find out who
they are all Europe help bring peace to
Syria after the conflict ends will the
refugees be expected to return to their
countries of origin I think we should
support people to go home if they have a
safe home that it's a condition for that
and I believe that the European Union
the Russians the Americans have to stick
together perhaps under the umbrella find
United Nations to cooperate with Ankara
tier an Arab area to stop the proxy was
there to have an influence in order to
isolate dash in order to make peace
possible in that region what is the rule
of the European Parliament in the
current refugees and migrants crisis do
the MEP s half power to arts upon it
european parliament has a right to
legislate and therefore the european
parliament will take part in this
legislation as a decisive power the
final world will come to an agreement
with the second chamber the Council of
Ministers therefore the migration
question and permanent mechanism in
order to avoid such crises in the future
right